let's start by talking about the
documentary warts-and-all for our
documentary
Hillary presently being screened on Skye
it focuses just for our viewers benefit
on your presidential campaign and how it
turns your life upside down and I
suppose I wanted to start by saying
America has been turned on its head in
the last few weeks with coronavirus and
black lives matter protest so let's
start with BLM if I'm a big part of the
2016 primary and presidential campaign
and I was reading up before our chat you
said in one of the debates unless there
is a policy change we'll be back here in
ten years time having the same
conversation four years time we're
already here what policy needs to change
well I said that because during the 2016
campaign from the very first speech that
I gave until the you know final votes
were counted I was stressing the
importance of dealing with racial
injustice certainly in our policing
system but in all of our institutions
sadly given what happened in that
election and the kind of leadership
we've had since then it has taken a
series of dreadful terrible killings to
awaken the attention of the majority in
our country about the need for real
change
[Applause]
[Music]
it's something that you will have a view
on is President Trump and his
intolerance of some protesters
describing them as thugs diss honoring
the memory of George Floyd and was he
right on any level no and here's why
there should be no tolerance for violent
protests and certainly that was not at
the core of the literally millions of
people who have come out to protest
peacefully over the last several weeks
the protestors that Trump tried to
characterize as thugs were the ones he
literally ordered our military to clear
from the square in front of the White
House I wanted to ask you actually
specifically about that and the fact
that he used tear gas on the protesters
they were totally peaceful protesters
and what he was trying to do as he often
does is to mischaracterize them and
their behavior and their goals and lock
them in with a tiny tiny minority of
people who took advantage of a tragic
moment to loot and to steal and to
vandalize a tiny tiny percentage and he
wanted to cast that over the millions of
you know very thoughtful nonviolent
peaceful protesters for a photo
opportunity well absolutely
for a photo opportunity holding a book
he's never read he says that it's one of
his favorite books yes and he can't tell
you a single thing that's in it that has
been a pattern he's tried to hijack
Christianity and the Bible in ways that
are you know deeply hypocritical and
that was just another occasion and the
outcry by religious leaders I think
demonstrated clearly that nobody was
being fooled
it's just awfully good that someone with
the temperament of Donald Trump is not
in charge of the law
in our country because you'd be in jail
Secretary Clinton you had a front-row
seat to a lot of president Trump's
personality quirks during the 2016
campaign
does he still surprise you four years
old yes yes and and here's why you know
obviously I tried to warn about him when
I was running against him and yet once
it was over
I hoped along with many Americans that
he would rise to the job that he would
not be as bad as I feared in the way
that he has be he had behaved in the
campaign sadly he's been even worse and
the kovat 19 crisis really sums up the
deep failures of his presidency we will
be today terminating our relationship
with the World Health Organization and
redirecting those funds to other
worldwide and deserving urgent global
public health needs his refusal to lead
to take any responsibility out of his
own mouth he says I don't take any
responsibility to heed the warnings that
were coming forward for quite some time
before the cases exploded to listen to
the scientists to reassure people to
lead by example none of that and then
finally he just got bored with it and he
thought it was hurting him in his
chances for re-election so there hasn't
been a taskforce meeting he hasn't
talked with the leading scientists in a
number of weeks and he's gone back to
trying to divert and deflect away from
his failures at that particular time in
our in our country history so he said to
launch her
for the president suppose to get Hillary
Clinton elected to be the 45th president
of the United States I provoked strong
opinions positive and negative I mean I
one time said to somebody who asked me
what do you want on your gravestone I
said she's neither as good nor as bad as
some people say about her something that
the documentary deals with the 2016
campaign as I said the polls had she was
the runaway winner
you lost why do you think you lost well
I wrote a whole book about it K I wrote
a book called what happened and I think
there were a number of factors and
obviously we were in a perfect storm the
final straw was what the director of the
FBI did in the last ten days of the
election which was to revive the you
know baseless accusations that were then
proven once again to be baseless but it
was a terrible setback to my campaign
and then Russia played a role and
WikiLeaks played a role there there were
a lot of factors and I would just add
this what happened to me with you know
the FBI director won't happen again but
Russian interference manipulation of
social media disinformation that is all
happening one more time and it's going
to have to be addressed by the Biden
campaign and I hope by the press to make
sure that you know people aren't fooled
again
I saw you in an Upper East Side
restaurant soon after the election and I
wanted to come over and give you a hug
because I can't begin to imagine how
hard it was to walk back into the light
after such a crushing defeat how did you
do it well it was really hard it was
incredibly painful because I had
expected to win that that seemed to you
know be what everyone thought literally
until it turned out I didn't but you
know I'm somebody who believes when you
get knocked down you get back up we have
to
about Monica Lewinsky how did you
forgive your husband the pen I would
have thrown things at him until there
was nothing left in the house to throw
well there I'm not saying I didn't do my
it was incredibly hard and it took a lot
of you know a lot of digging deep about
what I really wanted and what I could
live with going forward and at the end
of it we you know we had some counseling
we obviously spent an enormous amount of
time once I began talking to him again
talking it through I made the decision
that I thought was right for me and I am
quick to say I don't in any way suggest
or judge any woman who makes a different
decision let's talk about 2020 a Joe
Biden has vowed to pick a woman as his
running mate and any suggestions for I
am thrilled about that and obviously I
think it's long overdue but I I talked
to him periodically I talked quite
frequently to the leaders of this
campaign and I say look you've got three
important factors here number one this
person has to be ready to be President
because we don't know what's gonna
happen in this crazy world that we're
living in right now number two you've
got to want to work with this person day
in and day out and feel really good
about the partnership and then of course
number three this person has to help you
win or at least do no harm and you've
ruled yourself I I'm not even going to
go there what I am going to do just
before I let you go is ask you about
lock down challenges if I may please
mrs. Clinton lock down here I've not had
my hair cut for three months
hater tell me how do you cope how do you
go like a sheepdog
[Laughter]
and what about addressing for zoom chats
do you dress like from here and you've
got sweatpants on underneath
[Laughter]
I'm taking this dress shirt off as soon
as we're finished I finally before I let
you go who's gonna win the election Joe
Biden Joe how sure are you because you
expected you to win Anu didn't well I am
sure but I'm gonna work like crazy to
make sure it does happen okay okay there
is no doubt in my mind that if the
election were held Tuesday this coming
Tuesday he would win I just have to do
everything I can so that it's also true
the first Tuesday in November our
country is desperately out-of-the-world
is desperately in need of a change in
the American presidency
okay what's your final thought for
president Trump you is listening to this
afternoon you know just go away quietly
thank you very much go back to golfing
and whatever else you want to do just
don't you know continue to mess with our
country thank you